okay
tanisha are you there i am here okay
hold on are you going to keep your your
thing on your lanyard
this yeah
all righty all right we're going to
start off with uh with mike trudell
hey lebron it's mike trail back in los
angeles i just want to start asking you
about a couple of your teammates in that
third quarter once you guys went to the
bench
that small unit how how is that
impactful and how could that be even
more impactful moving forward
against a team like the clipper for the
matchup might be better
um well we have the ability to um you
know play different games
play different matchups have different
rotations
um i think j.r and dion
definitely gives us that even more of
that ability to go small i'm having
multiple ball hammers and scores on the
floor
i thought cruz was excellent tonight at
ac up
and we just tried to uh you know they
made a run which we know all great teams
are going to make a run in the third
quarter we're just trying to combat that
by making our own run
and then you know a.d caught fire just
started defending a little bit more
you guys had a couple of late of course
uh some from you some from kuzma
what was your mindset like defensively
in this game as you guys just
start getting integrated before the
playoffs come in in another a couple
weeks lebron
well i mean you know we've been out for
four months or
whatever whatever it was since the last
action we had versus uh
first brooklyn at staples center so um
you know rhythm is offensively making
shots those things are going to take a
little bit longer
um you know to get you know back to your
rhythm and your flow and how you shoot
the ball and things of that nature but
the one thing you can do
is defend because you can always
communicate you can communicate through
a mistake that you may happen
um you can you know you have teammates
that you know back you up and you do
make a mistake or whatever case may be
so
the communication and defensive side is
something that should always be on point
hey lebron it's david gunderman you
haven't played in la all that long but
tonight was the first time
since being a laker that you hit a go
ahead shot in the final 15 seconds of a
ball game to get the win
what are you looking for in those
situations obviously not every time is
is
equal but what does does your uh senses
get heightened or or
do you relish those those chances yeah i
mean um i love having a ball in my hands
you know late in the game tie game being
down
uh being up you know we had a we had a
three-point game like 40 seconds to go
we got a
um you know a great look for danny he
missed it paul george came back and hit
it ahead of three to tie the game and
uh for me just try to you know be
aggressive you know i feel like i got
some contact at the elbow
um you know by marcus morris i didn't
call it
um but you know like you know like he
was told he was a kid
just to start playing basketball there's
no whistle you keep playing on so
i was able to follow my shot and uh you
know put us up
and put us up for good hey lebron it's
bill orham
hey uh considering your support of
colleen kaepernick over the years
and and kind of what what
his journey has been like since he first
took and took a knee i'm curious what um
what that moment was for you personally
tonight
um oh we made cat proud we continue to
make cat proud
um you know every single day i hope i i
hope i
make them proud on how i live my life
not only you know i don't know
basketball floor but off the floor
you know i've been wanting to always
speak about speak out about things that
i feel like that's unjust
or unjust or and i always you know if
i'm educated on things i always
um you know go about it that way um so
you know cat was someone who
um who stood up when times wasn't
comfortable
but people didn't understand people
refused to listen
to what he was saying you go back and
look at any of his post-game interviews
when he was talking about why he was
kneeling
um had absolutely nothing to do about
the flag absolutely
nothing to do about the soldiers that
the men and women
that keep us uh keep our land free he
explained that
and the ears people never listened
they refused to listen um and uh i did
and a lot of my people um you know the
black community did listen
we just thank him for sacrificing um you
know everything that he did
to put us in today and even you know
years later to be able to have that
moment like we had tonight
ally yep thank you tanisha tanya
thank you
that kind of just happened but you know
if you're going
looking at any mind like when it's not
emotions or whatever the case may be on
social media i'm
putting that out as well you know just
having that that commitment to
the black community having my fists up
in the air i understand how unified
um you know my community not only in my
hometown
but all over the world you know how we
are
i want us to become and uh and us to be
heard
you know and then uh just giving thanks
to the man above for giving me an
opportunity to have this platform
you know because nothing is possible
without the grace of god and we all know
that he's giving us a breath of life
like i said using this platform using
who i am um
i try to use it for the greater good and
i hope i make people proud i hope i'm
you know make my kids part of my not
only my household but also
you know like my school and things of
that nature my community
kyle
you told us a couple days ago that one
of the things you really missed was
feeling those competitive juices
wondering this game but also that
sequence you had
with paul george kind of going faster
basket was that
sort of the thing you missed about
basketball absolutely you know playing
against the greatest
basketball players in the world at this
level this is the last level
this is the last level that you can get
as far as playing basketball and
you're fortunate to be able to i've been
playing against a lot of great players
that has graced this league over my
17-year career
and uh you know two of them was on the
floor tonight on the airport
you know just that competitive you know
and a spirit that that fight to
whatever you know you want to try to
help you know even if you're not
shooting the ball well you're not
playing particularly being able to do
things you can always help
in other ways either by your voice
working in a defensive stop or just uh
just your presence so that's that's
what's fun about the game
rachel nichols ryan you had uh
cp mellow handlebars
um you know i think it's a respect
and you know we're all brotherhood and
uh
you know definitely you know having cpa
mellow you guys i'm not really
those two guys but you know looking over
here and seeing some of our uh guys in
our league cj
uh you know
a lot of other guys um i think it's just
pretty cool
you know and i hope throughout the
course of this uh uh
this time where we're here in this
buzzword i can make it to a few games
too
just out of the love but the game i love
you know get an opportunity
um to watch the game live and you don't
have that much you don't have that much
uh
time throughout the course of you know
regular um you know nba scheduling
and before the the cold so you know it's
a pretty good dynamic it's a it's a big
like i said it's a big aau
uh feeling for for grown men
being here um how did you get talked
about being a brotherhood or being
players only sort of brothers across
teams but this has
never happened before to have you guys
all together no
it hasn't but um you know it's 20 20
people
you know 2020 is something that we've
never seen before so
um we are in the land of
the unknown and things are happening for
the first time
so you just take it for what it is
don't take the moment for granted
because we are still living and alive
and
we're back to doing what we love to do
either covering the game playing the
game or watching the game or being able
to report the game as you guys are doing
so
um you know that is a blessing you know
you know 2020 has been
pretty shitty you know but we're all
blessed okay we're gonna do three less
questions
taylor obviously very important
moment there's
[Music]
oh you really don't have a response
because no matter what you do in life
there's always going to be
people that won't agree with whatever
you do you can go to a fast food
restaurant and you can go to the
driveway and say well you didn't walk in
and get your food
you know it doesn't you you can wear
black and they say why didn't you wear
white
you know so no matter what you do in
life you're always going to have people
that will try to pick a part of whatever
you do but if you're
passionate and you're true and you're
authentic to whatever your cause is
then it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
and for me you guys should
actually know me i care less about the
naysayers i've been hearing it for
too long and uh i've been done about
caring about that
isn't that right yep we have two more so
joe and then bill plaschke will be your
last one
[Music]
about your evolution on that specific
thing because you don't
necessarily do things just with
everybody else yeah i just don't i don't
think at that point in time i wasn't
fully educated
you know strengthening the mind reading
listening
um getting as educated as i can be on
any situation on any
thing that's going on um has been always
who i am
you know and until i'm fully educated
and fully
i'm aware of what's going on then i
call for action so i i feel like at that
time i wasn't fully educated on
on the purpose uh what is the purpose at
hand
um and obviously cap has taught me a lot
about that so that's what it was
last question bill plaschke lebron by
the end of the game could you sense that
intensity was perhaps similar to what
you could have been playing back to
staples center against these guys oh
absolutely
absolutely um you know we're two teams
in the same city
um you know and two teams that's uh
fighting for one common goal and that's
to uh
win a championship and bring it to the
city of los angeles and their respective
fan base so um you know you have just so
many competitors on the floor
um you know so you know going out there
and representing the purple and gold
representing laker nation and those
those guys doing the same thing for
their fan base
no matter what the cause is no matter
what the bubble is
no fans or fans basketball is basketball
and competitive spirit is competitive
spirit so
we got right back to uh you know right
back to where we left off
appreciate it guys thank you thank you
tanisha thank you everybody on zoom
you're welcome my pleasure have a good
evening